>>> PUT UP OR SHUT UP.
THE SPECIAL MASTER IN THE
MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH CASE IS
ORDERING FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM TO PROVE
CLAIMS HE AND THEY HAVE MADE OUT
OF COURT THAT THE FBI PLANTED
EVIDENCE DURING THE SEARCH.
JUDGE RAYMOND DEARIE WHO TRUMP'S
TEAM RECOMMENDED FOR THE SPECIAL
MASTER ROLE SAID THE LAWYERS
MUST SUBMIT A SWORN DECLARATION,
WHICH IS UNDER OATH, OUTSIDE OF
COURT TRUMP AND HIS LEGAL TEAM
HAVE NOT FACED ANY CONSEQUENCES
FOR MAKING BASELESS AND FALSE
CLAIMS.
THEY SAID WITH NO PROOF THAT THE
FBI COULD HAVE PLANTED EVIDENCE.
>> AND QUITE HONESTLY I'M
CONCERNED THEY MAY HAVE PLANTED
SOMETHING.
WHO KNOWS.
I DON'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S A FRIGHTENING THING AS AN
AMERICAN.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT'S THERE THAT'S
WORTHWHILE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT THEY COME UP
WITH.
IF THEY DID, IT'LL BE
INTERESTING BECAUSE THEY
PRECLUDED ME FROM WATCHING WHAT
THEY DID.
BUT AT THIS POINT I DON'T THINK
THEY'D GO TO THE EXTENT OF
PLANTING INFORMATION.
I THINK THEY MAKE STUFF UP AND
COME UP WITH WHATEVER THEY WANT.
>> THE PROBLEM YOU HAVE IS THEY
GO INTO ROOMS, THEY WOULDN'T
EVEN LET ANYBODY IN THE SAME
BUILDING.
DID THEY DROP ANYTHING INTO
THOSE FILES OR DID THEY DO IT
LATER?
THERE'S NO CHAIN OF CUSTODY HERE
WITH THEM.
>> WOULDN'T THAT BE ON VIDEOTAPE
POTENTIALLY?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
THEY WERE IN A ROOM.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID
PUBLICLY.
WILL THEY SAY IT UNDER OATH.
LET'S BRING IN POLITICAL ANALYST
AND SENIOR POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT FOR "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" MAGGIE HABERMAN.
HER NEW BOOK COMES OUT ON
OCTOBER 4th.
MAGGIE, IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
FIRST TIME SOMETHING THAT TRUMP
OR HIS LAWYERS HAVE SAID
PUBLICALLY IS BEING TESTED IN
COURT, BUT I WONDER WHAT YOU
THINK THE STAKES ARE IN THIS
CASE?
>> SO IN THIS CASE, BRIANNA, I
THINK THE STAKES ARE PRETTY
CLEAR, WHICH THIS IS THE HAND
PICKED SPECIAL MASTER WHO DONALD
TRUMP'S TEAM WANTED AND HE
SOUNDS SKEPTICAL OF THINGS
THEY'VE BEEN SAYING ALL WEEK,
NOT JUST IN THIS DECISION THAT
CAME DOWN YESTERDAY BUT IN A
CONFERENCE EARLIER THIS WEEK HE
SOUNDED VERY EYEBROW RAISING
ABOUT THEIR CLAIMS.
THE SPECIAL MASTER WAS -- THEY
HAVE PRIVATELY DESCRIBED THIS AS
A FIRST STEP TOWARD A POSSIBLE
EVENTUAL CHALLENGE OF THE FBI
SEARCH ON TRUMP'S HOUSE.
IT'S NOT GOING WELL.
SO WHEN THE SPECIAL MASTER IS
MAKING IT CLEAR YOU CAN'T SAY
THINGS OUTSIDE OF COURT YOU'RE
NOT DEMONSTRATING HERE.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
I THINK THIS IS WHAT WE SAW
AFTER THE NOVEMBER 2020 ELECTION
WHERE DONALD TRUMP'S LAWYERS
WOULD MAKE CLAIMS ABOUT
WIDESPREAD FAUD THEY WOULDN'T
ECHO IN COURT.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS THE IMPACT
OF WHEN TRUMP SAYS SOMETHING AND
IT RILES UP HIS SUPPORTERS I
HAVE TO WONDER IF THAT'S IN THE
SPECIAL MASTER'S MIND AS WELL.
>> IF YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING, PROVE IT.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SAY IT, PROVE
IT.
THIS GOT A LOT OF ATTENTION,
MAGGIE, I WANT TO PLAY IT NOW.
YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT TAKE ON IT.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP WITH SEAN
HANNITY.
>> IS THERE A PROCESS WHAT WAS
YOUR PROCESS --
>> THERE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A
PROCESS, AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S DIFFERENT
PEOPLE SAY DIFFERENT THINGS.
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, YOU CAN
DECLASSIFY BY SAYING IT'S
DECLASSIFIED, EVEN BY THINKING
ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE YOU'RE SENDING IT TO
MAR-A-LAGO OR WHEREVER YOU'RE
SENDING IT.
AND THERE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A
PROCESS.
THERE CAN BE A PROCESS BUT THERE
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT YOU MAKE
THAT DECISION.
WHEN YOU SEND IT, IT'S
DECLASSIFIED.
I DECLASSIFIED EVERYTHING.
>> MAGGIE, MOST PEOPLE PICKED UP
ON THE IDEA OF DECLASSIFYING IN
HIS MIND AS BEING SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T EXIST ON PLANET EARTH.
BUT YOU PICKED UP ON SOMETHING
ELSE THAT MIGHT BE LEGALLY
PROBLEMATIC FOR HIM THERE.
>> I PICKED UP ON BOTH, JOHN.
SAYING THAT HE DECLASSIFIED
SOMETHING WITH HIS MIND --
>> YOU PICKED UP SOMETHING ALSO,
I SHOULD SAY, YEAH.
>> RIGHT.
I DON'T WANT THIS TO SOUND AS IF
IT WAS IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE
THAT WAS UNUSUAL TO HEAR.
BUT HE DID SAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
SENDING IT TO MAR-A-LAGO, THAT,
JOHN, SEEMED TO INDICATE THAT HE
HAD INTENDED TO SEND THE BOXES
OF MATERIAL TO HIS PRIVATE CLUB
AND HOME WHEREAS THERE HAS BEEN
THIS LINE FROM PEOPLE AROUND HIM
THIS WAS ALL YOU KNOW AN
ACCIDENT, THINGS WERE SHIPPED
OUT.
HE SAID HIMSELF IN THE
INTERVIEW, WHICH IS NOT PROVED,
THE GENERAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION, BASICALLY
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS, HAD PACKED
THE BOXES, THEY DENIED THEY DID
THAT.
THEY TRIED LEANING IN ON THE
IDEA THIS WAS SOME KIND OF
ACCIDENT AND JUST NOW HE SEEMED
TO SUGGEST IT WAS INTENTIONAL.
>> IT'S NOT THE ONLY LEGAL ISSUE
HE'S FACING, OF COURSE.
THERE'S THIS CIVIL FRAUD SUIT
NOW THAT HE'S FACING THAT
LETICIA JAMES, THE NEW YORK AG
HAS BROUGHT AND, YOU KNOW,
MAGGIE WHENEVER WE SEE ANY LEGAL
ACTION AGAINST TRUMP, HE'S ABLE
TO SAY, LOOK, THEY'RE AFTER ME.
BUT I WONDER IN THIS CASE, DOES
THIS HIT ON ANY VULNERABILITY OF
HIS THAT IS PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE, AS YOU SEE IT?
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
HAVING A PROSECUTOR STAND UP
THERE AND SAY HE IS NOT WORTH
WHAT HE CLAIMS, HE HAS MADE ALL
KINDS OF STATEMENTS ABOUT HIS
FINANCES THAT ARE NOT TRUE IS
SOMETHING HE HAS TRIED TO AVOID
FOR MANY, MANY DECADES.
JUST ON A PERSONAL LEVEL FOR HIM
THAT CUTS A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
HOW THIS ENDS UP PLAYING OUT, I
DON'T THINK WE KNOW YET.
AGAIN THIS IS A CIVIL SUIT AS
BEST AS I CAN TELL SHE'S NOT
MAKING ANY MOVES IN COURT TO TRY
TO LIMIT WHAT THE TRUMPS CAN DO
IN BUSINESS WHILE THE SUIT IS
PLAYING OUT.
THAT DOES SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
HOW AGGRESSIVELY SHE'S MOVING OR
NOT AGGRESSIVELY SHE'S MOVING.
BUT IT IS ANOTHER THING HE WILL
POINT TO TO SAY I AM A VICTIM,
THEY'RE AFTER ME.
HE HAS BEEN, I THINK, THE
BIGGEST DEMAGOGUE WE HAVE SEEN
IN POLITICS, IN NATIONAL
POLITICS IN THIS COUNTRY IN
MODERN MEMORY, POSSIBLY THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
AND HE'S VERY GOOD USING ANY
TIME SOMEBODY IS LOOKING INTO
POSSIBLE MISCONDUCT OR ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT SAYING HOW UNFAIR IT
IS.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING YOU TOLD ANDERSON THE
OTHER NIGHT, WHICH MAKES IT MORE
LESS LIKELY OR NOT HE'LL RUN
FROM PRESIDENT.
YOU SAID SOMETHING SEPARATE FROM
THIS.
YOU'RE HEARING PEOPLE AROUND HIM
QUESTIONING WHETHER HE WANTS TO
PUT THE EFFORT IN AGAIN.
EXPLAIN THAT MORE.
>> SURE.
SO TO BE CLEAR, JOHN.
THAT DOESN'T PRECLUDE WHETHER
HE'S GOING TO RUN.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF CANDIDATES
WHO HAVE RUN EVEN IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THEIR HEART IN IT.
PEOPLE SAID HE DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE ENJOYING POLITICS, RALLIES,
THE ASPECTS OF IT HE LIKED
BEFORE, NOT JUST WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT BUT IN THE 2016
CAMPAIGN THAT IT JUST SEEMS SORT
OF DIFFERENT FOR HIM AND HE
DOESN'T SEEM AS EITHER
INTERESTED OR ENGAGED OR WHAT
HAVE YOU, HE MAY GET THERE, IT
COULD CHANGE AND IF IT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE HIM RUNNING, THEN IT
HAS LIMITED UTILITY AS AN
OBSERVATION.
BUT IT HAS RAISED QUESTIONS FOR
PEOPLE ABOUT WHY HIS -- NOT HIS
DEADLINE BUT HIS TIMING FOR WHEN
HE WOULD GET IN HAD KEPT MOVING
BACK.
NOW I EXPECT IT WILL REMAIN
BEYOND THE MIDTERMS THIS MORNING
THERE'S A POLITICO REPORT OUT
ABOUT MOVES HE IS MAKING AND
THAT WILL LOCK HIM IN FURTHER
BUT HE HAS NOT SEEMED LIKE THE
PERSON WHO CAMPAIGNED IN 2016
AND THAT COULD BE FOR A LOT OF
REASONS.
>> IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
BECAUSE THESE ARE THINGS THAT
HAVE ANIMATED HIM, ENERGIZED HIM
AND NOW MAYBE NOT SO MUCH.
WHAT ALL IS BEHIND THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MAGGIE GREAT
TO HAVE YOU THIS MORNING.
JOINING ME TO TALK ABOUT THIS IS
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR JOSEPH
MARINO.
THIS APPEARS TO BE THE SPECIAL
MASTER CALLING TRUMP'S BLUFF.
WHAT ARE THE MOVES HERE HIS
LAWYER CAN MAKE?
>> AS I'M WATCHING THIS, SERVED
ON THE DEFENSE SIDE, MY HEART IS
PALPITATING.
THIS IS EVERY DEFENSE NIGHTMARE,
THEIR CLIENT GOES OUT AND SAYS
THING AND AT SOME POINT YOU GET
CALLED TO THE CARPET, THE JUDGE
SAYS YOU SAID THESE THINGS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, SAID THEM IN
PUBLIC STATEMENTS, EVEN COURT
FILINGS, WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
SOUNDS LIKE PROBABLY NOT MUCH.
THIS IS REMINISCENT OF THE TIMES
IN THE POST 2020 ELECTION WHEN
THE TRUMP TEAM MADE THESE
OUTLANDISH ARGUMENTS IN PUBLIC
ABOUT ALL THESE VOTING
IRREGULARITIES AND THINGS BUT
EVERY TIME THEY WERE UNABLE TO
BRING EVIDENCE THIS COURT.
THEY BETTER WATCH THEMSELVES
THIS JUDGE DEARIE IS NOT HAVING
IT.
THEY HAVE TO PUT UP OR SHUT UP.
>> DO YOU THINK THE SPECIAL
MASTER PROCESS HAS MAYBE
BACKFIRED FOR TRUMP?
>> IF THE GOAL OF THE TRUMP TEAM
WAS TO BUY ITSELF SOME TIME, I
GUESS IT'S DONE THAT.
THE SPECIAL MASTER IS IN PLACE
AND HAS TO NOVEMBER 30th TO DO
HIS JOB.
IF THE GOAL WAS TO GET AN
ADVANTAGE OR KEEP ANY OF THESE
DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM MAR-A-LAGO
OUT OF EVIDENCE, IT'S NOT GOING
WELL AT ALL.
IF ANYTHING IT'S SHOWING THE
HYPOCRISIES OF THE TEAM.
RIGHT NOW, PER THE 11th CIRCUIT,
ALL DOCUMENTS MARKED CLASSIFIED
ARE OUT OF THE SPECIAL MASTER'S
HANDS BACK TO THE DODGE.
AND JUDGE DEARIE IS SAYING I'M
SKEPTICAL ABOUT PRIVILEGE HERE.
SO MAYBE HE JUST BOUGHT HIMSELF
A LITTLE EXTRA TIME ON THE
CALENDAR.
>> BUT ALSO A LITTLE EXTRA
HUMILIATION.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT STOPS HIM.
I THINK HE SEES IT AS A BADGE OF
HONOR.
IT WOULD WHORROR FIE ME.